I hate to break it to you but your
laptop is fat that's right your laptop
needs to cut back on the fatty foods
especially the chips get it I mean
really you get it right ah even the
Apple MacBook Air and the Dell XPS 13
seem chunky in comparison to this new
wave of insanely thin laptops like this
HP spectre 13 at point 4 1 inches thick
HP claims it's the thinnest laptop in
the world Apple's MacBook is an
unnoticeable point one inches thicker
but like any diet you need to decide how
much you're willing to give up before
you buy a laptop that can double as a
cheese knife make sure you weigh the
laptops Nutrition Facts the first one to
look for ports they're the laptop
calorie equivalent of ice cream
the MacBook has just a single USB port
and it's not even the one you've known
the USB type-c socket can be used to
charge the laptop and also attached
peripherals you'll want to buy something
like this $45 hyper drive USB hub to
attach your accessories the HP on the
other hand has three USB type-c ports
two of which support faster thunderbolt
speeds second consider the keyboard and
trackpad sacrifices your fingers will
thank you the MacBook and the specter
are both as flat as a pancake which
means there's less space for keys with
real height the map books completely
flat keys take some real getting used to
you may be put off by the specter subpar
trackpad and tacky external design new
HP hired Kanye West but it does manage
to have a quite pleasing traditional
keyboard and the new logo is awesome
does it say HP or lip lastly you need to
weigh the performance first the heat and
battery life trade-off the quiet MacBook
is powered by a new Intel Core M
processor that makes it faster than last
year's model it's fine for juggling
email web browsing and other basic apps
but it still slows down during graphics
intensive tasks the HP on the other hand
has a full Core i5 processor it's as
fast as any regular lab
but gets warm and the fan can sound like
it's getting ready for take off the map
book ran for nearly nine hours on my web
browsing test The Spectre just six and a
half the Dell XPS in the MacBook Air run
for 11 hours the sacrifices you make for
a crazy thin laptop are diminishing over
time just look at how much better the
sleek MacBook got in just a year
still need to ask yourself how much do
you value portability and I mean really
value the MacBook starts at $1300 and
the HP just shy of twelve hundred
dollars you can get a MacBook Air or a
Dell XPS 13 for eight hundred dollars
just know this though when you start
carrying around one of these your old
laptop really will seem fat